foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome
to another 3D Community challenge my
name is Clinton Jones
also known as The Punisher
and uh we're hanging out today I'm gonna
help you guys get through this boss
fight we're gonna come up to my with
some ideas we're going to talk about the
challenge a little bit
um get the juices flowing you know
um I'm gonna answer any questions you
guys have for FAQs what this is all
about
but this is a very big moment for myself
for all the moderators because we spent
the last like month I feel like more
like a month and a half working on this
and uh it all comes together today
um and I I couldn't be more excited for
it all this this happens twice a year we
do these twice a year
and uh it's so good to see all you guys
in the chat I love that you guys are all
so excited for this
um because I am too really
um like okay so we did this twice a year
right as as most of you guys know at
this point
um and uh one in February one in August
and this prompt this boss fight prompt
is like one of my favorites I feel that
way every time we do these and that's a
good sign if this is your first
challenge if this is your first time
participating in a 3D Community
challenge
like give me give me a little hand raise
in the chat I want to see you guys
um
because yes it is kind of scary right it
is a little bit scary to join these
things but it it shouldn't be
um I know it is sometimes but really
these are just for fun this is this is
for fun and um yeah there's winners yeah
there's prizes but at the end of the day
using this as a chance for you guys to
to level up to get into 3D maybe for the
first time if you've never done it
before we've had people in the past who
are like
I've I've never done 3D before but this
challenge is my way in and it's a chance
for me to to learn it so
um if you're just doing it to learn like
really that's the point yes guys we have
so many hands so many hands
oh amazing amazing amazing if you guys
are
um if you've done a challenge before
give me give me a smiley face I want to
see how many people we have returning
um to these challenges yeah guys we have
a lot of hands this is so good
um
amazing so I kind of got like two two
audiences in a sense
um we have people who are here for the
first time who don't know kind of the
the the the details and the the
particulars of the challenge and we have
the people who've done it before as well
also we got my friend Devon chilling
here as well Devon Sun what up son good
to see you man I miss you I miss you
we got some smiley faces up in here too
yes yes you guys we got some returning
artists yeah my camera's glitching I
know
I don't know what maybe it's a cave it's
probably my cable it's got to be the
cable it's an old camera too
oh snap I gotta pour my tea what am I
doing over steep the tea can you check
this out
look at this I got this little teeth
infuser thing
it's from the leaf of a tree in India
and then this like look at this
beautiful Cup oh my God this beautiful
cup look at this beautiful little teapot
oh yeah
we got some some tea from uh my buddy
came over from China and brought some
fancy tea
it's good stuff
um
I was in Portland recently you know a
couple weeks ago you see me all bandaged
up
you know busted myself
my shoulder my like here let me see if I
can yeah
you know this was all just like
it's me
all up in here I fell off my bike
Hit the Dirt it's a little slip and
slide
um but I was there for a little tea
festival and a bike ride this is the
most Portland thing you could possibly
do in Portland and uh we made it happen
and I went deep with the tea let me tell
you
all right so the challenge guys the
challenge we're hanging out here for the
next two hours and talking challenge
ideas hanging out with you guys this is
really a celebration a launch
celebration
um and a way to hang out with you guys
so
um here's here's the info you saw the
announcement video
um if you didn't see the announcement
video go watch the announcement video on
my channel
and then come back here but basically
the idea is that uh
we have these project files we put
together for you let me show you the
project file
also look at that sweet intro that
sodomonte made
like in the nick of time like in the
final hour he made that intro or that
transition I love it
um so boom right here guys we got the
project file and the rules and this
weird green circle like what the heck
um we got project files for for most
popular programs of choice right we got
blender of course Unreal Engine Maya
um Houdini even we got fbxusd the only
one we don't have right now is 3ds Max
um but maybe we'll patch that in the
future it's just none of us use it so
it's it's tough all of these project
files were made by
um first first is the c4d file me and
the mods got together we were like yes
this is what we want to do and then I
send this c4d slash fbx to the mods
sodomonte put together the blender and
Houdini file shout outs MDK put together
the Maya one and cybo put together the
unreal one
um
so this is what you're gonna see this is
the close one there's actually three
different ones there's three different
like versions three different distances
of the same project file and it's not
like you have to do all three you pick
one of them that's all you have to do is
pick one right there's a far one as well
because this far one if you notice look
how far away the boss is from the hero
so you can do stuff like let's see so
you can do stuff like this right that's
that boss is far away
right
um and you wouldn't be able to do it if
you were in the close one like say this
is uh
you know
I don't know you versus a giant Knight
or something
so we just wanted to give you guys as
many uh let's get this over here as many
I gotta get my stuff back together
there we go
boom as many options as possible
to allow for the most ideas as possible
right so you can download those project
files that's what you're going to find
inside also inside you're gonna find
some reference files let me get that
going for you guys real quick bam
starter files
references so in these references you're
going to find these viewport exports
and this is just kind of there for you
guys to like essentially use as as
reference when you open your project
file
um and if you think your project file
looks weird you can kind of do a
viewport export or you know and overlay
it with this or just watch this and
compare it and be like yeah
mine matches this perfectly we are good
to go
um and then we have these example
renders by visual which you guys already
saw in the announcement um
announcement video in the starting
screen and this is just kind of a way to
like give you guys an idea of like the
scope of what you can do with this of
course we're going to see renders that
go far beyond you know what we could
come up with in like a week or so just
as an example for the video but like
notice here like yeah this is this is
like the typical humanoid boss in front
big boss in front of the hero but also
look this guy is just a torso and this
totally passes he's got Wings coming out
to the side this one is a giant like eye
or hole or something that fills the
whole frame but that passes too same
here it's just a hand but it fills that
that point in in space there which we're
calling the area of Interest that's what
this green circle is for
so
all of these renders are going to
combine together right into a montage
and the only way for the Montage to flow
properly is if you guys keep your your
boss in this area of Interest right
that's why it's called area of Interest
boss right
um
so it could be like you know like the
example videos it could be a giant like
thing here where it's just like
it's torso and he's like oh and he's
trying to smack you with his palms or
something this is the close project file
right
and he's like worming around you know
stuck in some quicksand and he's trying
to grab you in or something I don't know
um that could totally pass right so all
these different ideas as long as you're
working in the area of interest and
filling it it could be a freaking giant
skull head thing
that's totally cool too
as long as it's up in that area of
interest because that is where the eye
is going to be
in these montages everyone's going to be
looking at the center excuse me
right so that's the whole thing with the
area of interest
um
what else
these are all mentioned all this stuff
is mentioned in the Discord so if you
guys want to join the Discord server I
got a link below and in the Discord
server as most of you guys know at this
point it is our home base during these
3D challenges right so we have a get
started page where you guys can get all
the rules all the all the uh you can
download the project file you can read
up on the prizes you can hear about the
guest judge the guest musician which by
the way is insane I cannot believe
that we got disasterpiece and Rafael
Garcetti could join us for this thing
that is insane I've been a
Piper light Drifter fan and a fez fan
and just yeah disasterpieces music is my
all-time favorite and uh
yeah I'm like I'm very very excited to
see what he puts together we have any
disasterpiece fans in the chat give me
like give me a heart or something here I
want to see if you guys if you guys know
who disaster piece is
um yeah super unique uh electronic
musician uh yeah the dude the dude is
incredible
um
and then of course we got Rafael
grossetti who is like the freaking man
one of the best 3D sculptors in the
business wasn't one of the best
character designers in the business he
did God of War Kratos for the new God of
War series
um he's worked with DC Marvel
um uh he worked over at Ubisoft like the
list goes on and on and like dude they
won game of the year
um they almost won game of the of the
year uh this year I guess it was this
year right
it last year I forget time flies man
jeez
so it's insane right yeah it's
absolutely ridiculous that disaster
peace and Raph versetti are joining us
for this one
um
it's gonna be a good month it's going to
be a really really good month I'm gonna
do a piece of art with you guys last
year or not last year feels like last
year
um for Endless engines I didn't get
around to doing a piece I was too busy
running the challenge and
um juggling too many plates at the same
time but this time this time is a
different story guys I'm doing it I'm
doing it and I'm gonna start my idea
here with you on the stream
um with some sketches and whatnot I'm
really excited for it I have a couple
ideas in mind
um hit me with your questions please hit
me with your questions eggy you got a
good question can you use pre-made
models yes you can use pre-made bottles
um yes you can use assets I mean guys uh
kid bash 3D is one of the challenge
sponsors this time around they came out
with cargo
if you know about cargo it's basically a
super sweet asset library of all of
their kid bash assets and instead of
having to buy a 200 kit you can use
cargo for free and you have access to
like 125 or so models and textures so
you can definitely definitely use that
utilize that for this challenge of
course it's free we got embergen as well
Jenga effects they're stepping in
um they're giving you guys Amber gen for
free for the entire month there's
there's a link down below all the
sponsor links are down below
um normally I think evergen is like 300
bucks but it's free for this month
um for boss fights specifically so go go
download that get some smoke get some
fog get some fire some explosions into
your renders
um what else what else um I mean of
course for Coco they have her cocoa
video that's their free motion capture
solution like no suit is needed
um you just film yourself and it
processes you a nice motion capture clip
you can use that in your renders as well
so lots of really great assets that you
guys are going to be able to use
um for free during this challenge right
um hit me with the app punishers I can
see it a little bit better in the chat
the chat is flying right now and I'm
gonna do my best to answer your
questions your your challenge specific
questions here
um
Infinity monk says can we make the boss
appear or does it have to be there from
the beginning great question
um totally you can have them intro you
can have them like if you want them to
like pop out of the ground or something
that's totally fine but just make sure
that the boss and the hero are both
visible in your sequence in your five
second hundred 120 frame render for the
majority of that render we don't want to
be sitting on on nothing orbiting
nothing you want to be orbiting that
boss pretty quickly so but yes it can
come in it can pop in transition
transition in transition out totally
fine
um
let's see can we make models of
copyrighted materials like can I scope
Raphael from Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles yes please do that that's fine
you can use iped characters
um it's all just for fun
um it's just going in a big Montage on
YouTube that's totally fine you guys can
do that
um does the hero have to stand or can he
swim or fly
um yeah so you guys can move the hero
around that's that's like that's one
thing you can do here
um technically yes you can move the boss
around let me let me get back to the
project file
hahaha
man that transition is so sweet thank
you so much for that that's awesome
um so yes
um can you move the hero yes you can
move the hero right so let's say we're
doing hero versus giant skull can they
be swimming or flying yes that's totally
fine the the point is to just keep the
action centered we don't want your hero
like way off up here and they're just up
here and this boss is just like uh let
me see if I can do this
yeah yep just gotta get it
like we don't want this battle like this
you know like keep it centered to keep
it centered it's I think it's rule
number three keep the action centered so
you can move your hero around yes
but just keep your actions centered
please
um because this is kind of this is where
the eye is throughout the montages right
so keep that in mind
um
so if you guys can figure that out if
you can find a way that it's your Your
Heroes swimming or flying and keeping
the action centered then we're good to
go
uh what else what else
we got some more questions hit me with
the app punishers oh we got a lot of
questions
um Can the hero end up killing the boss
kill the boss yeah why not
why is the camera pink and blender I
don't know
um
can you do a group
um wait settlement you had to answer did
you did you answer in my head or did you
come up on the chat
you have to unzip the file first and
then you can see it that's what Soto
said in my ear
um
let's see what else what else
um can you do a group versus the big
monster uh technically yes
um your hero just needs to be the like
standout main one so there can be a
group around your hero but your hero
needs to be like featured and clearly
stand out in the crowd
um let's see can you use AI generated
art and compose it with blender
hmm that one's tricky I don't know I
feel like this is a 3D challenge the
point is to build out a 3D scene
um maybe if you want to add some like
some style stuff towards the end that
might be a bit more chill but for now
um the point is to create it in 3D
um or create assets outside and then
bring them all and compose them in 3D
um so I I don't know that one's a little
iffy I don't think you can just generate
an AI thing hit hit go and submit that
that's that's probably not chill
um does it have to be humanoid hero no
it does not have to be a human or hero
um how how you interpret boss fight is
up to you guys
um let's see
does it have to be a boss fight or can
it be like a deity in a devoted follower
ooh
well that's similar to an FAQ we have in
on the Discord
um side of things it was like does it
have to be adversarial does it have to
be a battle and I think our answer was
chair I think it was like
I think our answer was how you interpret
boss fight is up to you so we're kind of
keeping it open
um
I'll I'll say that I'll say how you
interpret boss fight is up to you can we
make army an army with a focus on the
main character yeah I already kind of
answered that one can we transition from
the close to far cameras
[Music]
I mean that's crazy if you figure out a
way to make that work I guess
um
yeah
um if it yeah if it fits in the Montage
you know
we have this saying I don't even know if
it's a saying we have this thing that we
kind of started adding from the third
challenge fourth Challenge on which was
basically
we have all these rules in place not all
we're not a ton of rules it's like not
that many but we have we have the rules
in place to essentially
um guide you guys
so that all the all the art all the
renders fit in the Montage so that they
flow back to back in the Montage
right
and if you think you have an idea that's
like crazy that's outside the box please
go for it just know that it's like a
it's a creative risk you might be
bending a rule pretty hard you know if
it fits in and it works and it flows and
it looks nice and it's good then
you know
I I wouldn't see why it couldn't pass
um but that's on you that's on you
um what's next
[Music]
I have a serious question
Papi has a serious question
why are the deadlines so short like a
month is fine but I would love to see a
challenge that lasts at least two months
to include those that take more time to
complete to complete
um a month is perfect in my mind because
it's punctual it's like two months if I
put out a challenge and it's like it's a
two-month challenge guarantee you people
are gonna be like ah I'll get to it you
know I'll get to it and then they won't
get to it
um one month to me is perfect just
because it's like oh we got a month we
gotta hit the ground running let's go
um so it feels it feels pretty active to
me it feels like a nice balance also
and the last one was five weeks we did
five weeks instead of four
um
I don't know yeah I think that's my best
answer
I think that's definitely my best answer
yeah you can maybe make something better
in two months but
you know why not three months
or longer
I think a month is good
um let's see
still going down the list here questions
[Music]
can you do frame by frame frame
animation
um
why not as long as like it matches the
camera the the project
um starter files and why not
oh
see
a lot of these I already answered
can the boss move yes the boss can move
totally the boss can move
um but they need to stay within the area
of of of Interest right here this green
circle they can move around within the
area of Interest they can like turn
around they can like smash whatever
um of course they can move they just
have to be up in that area of Interest
they can't like
walk off to the right and be done with
it you know it's got they're they're
kind of planted there
um
but of course they can move yeah
does the boss have to be a villain
opposing the hero or do they just have
to be a large large and menacing
um
you know that one is I think the spirit
and the Heart of the challenge is it's a
it's like David versus Goliath you know
it's a
boss fight kind of a thing
um you know but again how you interpret
boss fight is up to you well I'll just
leave it leave that there
how many frames per second
I have
where did that go
how many frames per second do I have to
use and does it have to be animated
well yeah um that's kind of the whole
thing of the challenge is it's uh 120
frames
long which is five seconds at 24 frames
per second
yeah guys we doing video animations
um
[Music]
it's fan art okay yeah
um
fight need to be centered the whole time
pretty much yeah keep the action center
framed keep the action centered we don't
want like
uh you know I kind of went over this but
we don't want like a profile shot going
you know uh
like this
control y
'all you know because this is just like
now my eyes like way up here you want to
keep it centered keep the action
centered in this in this kind of main
area
um
that's the goal
photorealistic renders have a judging
bias when compared to more stylistic or
creative ones
um that's kind of that's a good question
so I mean no first off no
um but
here's the thing when I'm going through
these thousands of renders okay this is
this is Warren's uh full screen here
the question is will photorealistic
renders have a judging bias when
compared to more stylistic or creative
ones
um
here so here's here's the long answer
basically I'm going through the
thousands of submissions okay
and all I see is the same style I'm not
going to say what style but I see the
same style for hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds and eventually
it's like all right guys I get it we've
seen this style and
if something
I mean yeah this is kind of this is like
I don't know if something catches my eye
if you do that style really well then of
course yeah boom
um you know you go up but
uh if everyone's doing the same thing
then it starts to like my my meter for
like oh that's sick kind of goes when
you see it so much
um
so then you suddenly see another style
and it's like oh that's interesting
that doesn't mean they automatically get
the up but it's like
if they do it really it all comes down
to how well you do it that that's really
what it comes down to the judging
process it all just comes down to
how good of a job did you do
you know did you knock out the
photorealism style
you go up did you knock out the anime
style you go up like every style is
passable on this thing
um it's just a matter of how well you'd
pull off the style if you have
a thousand people doing the same style
then you're kind of up against you know
all those other people if you have a the
same idea as a thousand other people
you know you're kind of up against those
thousand other people with that same
idea
and the best ones from there will go up
I guess that's the simplest that's not
the simplest way that's like that was
like a two minute answer
um but I hope you guys get where I'm
coming from
can you use AI for some elements yeah
you can use AI for some elements I'm not
I I just don't want you guys to like
generate a whole AI thing hit done and
and submit that would not be chill
um but to supplement to uh
to come up with ideas you know that's
totally fine
all right man there's a million
questions how do you guys feeling is
Gore allowed how much more
um
generally yeah if you get don't get me
flagged if you can be flagged them I'll
have to pull it don't get me flagged
um
let's see can the hero die in the
animation why not
can you change the scale of the hero
that's a great question not really keep
the hero about the same size please
we want it kind of big versus small
um if you want to scale the boss and the
hero relatively right so as as one gets
smaller the other one does too so that
would just be a scene skill change you'd
have to figure that out but uh like do a
miniature version right
like a cockroach versus a big shoe or
something
you know
that's totally fine
can there be two giants fighting each
other and the hero is watching from a
distance
or better yet to have the hero do
movements that the giant copies to
defeat the other boss like Real Steel
um yes but you need to utilize the area
of Interest so one of the bosses has to
be like I don't know the main boss or
something and they got to be up in that
area of Interest
can you move the horizon line
if you can make it work
see
Edge yes Edge I'm excited I'm excited
absolutely love the theme this time
around what are some of the key aspects
you and RAF will be looking for in good
submissions
great question great question
um
so
what are some key aspects you and RAF
will be looking for in a good submission
I think by default
when I'm pulling the top 100 and I'm
pulling because before Raph even gets to
um judge before I even sit down with
Raph I'm gonna pull a
like a pre-selected uh like top 20
essentially for us and Raph to go
through and put in order pool top five
put those in order from from first to
fifth right so I'm like there's only so
much time the man has right I'm not
gonna sit down and do every single
render uh with RAF because that takes
literally two days
so it's me and uh me and the moderators
we go through everything
together and we pull the top 100
together and then I'll pull the top like
20 or so 25 and then that's what goes to
Raph so
but when you get to that point I don't I
don't know um I think I can speak a
little bit more globally like what top
100 first off we'll start off with that
um to me the first thing is render
quality
lighting
animation
um
composition
those those four things render quality
it can look great but if it's animated
really janky
um then you kind of shoot yourself in
the foot there you know
the animation is super good
but the lighting is just like what are
you doing once again kind of shooting
yourself in the foot there so it's it's
a combination of those things
um your lighting you know get your
lighting nice your composition do we see
all the elements in your scene like do
either are all of the main your hero
your boss do they stand out are they lit
well they lit in a dramatic fun unique
clear way right
um that's the lighting right render
quality of course is uh well sorry
lighting composition
um animation
yeah
you can do those things well but if your
animation is looking freaking crunch
town
that's that's tough that's tough It's
gotta gotta be smooth and I think
correct me if I'm wrong here but I think
um
incorporating rule number two
incorporate a sense of slow motion
I think that's gonna help you guys out
with the animation because you don't
have to animate some crazy thing
some fast sequence it can be super
slow-mo and you can you can cut a lot of
corners and hide a lot of jankiness with
that slow motion depending on how you
incorporate the slow motion okay
so animation has got to be nice
um what else render quality how do you
you know get your samples going come on
get your samples going give yourself
enough time to render out a nice uh a
nice final render at the end of the day
and if you're going into uh you know
after effects or Da Vinci to do some
post-processing
then how are you taking your render to
really maximize everything right
um making sure everything's clear giving
yourself a little film grain right so to
me that would be all render quality how
beautiful are you making those other
three things
what else what else
once you have all that okay then it's
like all right what are you doing with
it what are you doing with it and that's
where story and the unique idea your
unique idea comes into play all right
and those are the two that like you can
have render quality animation you know
uh lighting and uh
what is it was it lighting animation
composition render coin you can have
those things and still get into top 100
that's fine
but now it's like okay well how good is
the story how good is the idea itself
um how unique is it how like you know
what what's what's the cool idea that
you have what's the unique idea right
I'm saying the same thing over and over
I think you get the point
so if you can take
those four base things and really
maximize and and hit it with a nice idea
and a nice story and get an emotional
reaction
man I'm not saying emotional like you
have to make you cry or anything I'm
saying like
like is there a satisfying element to it
is there
um like
of you know does it make me think does
it feel unique all that kind of stuff
right
that's where it gets into like oh man
they're doing some spice on top of some
spice
to me it's just like
you can have a movie that looks nice
like most movies are shot really well
and are lit really nicely and are
blocked and composed beautifully
they sound amazing
but they don't do anything for me that's
like most movies
um so it comes down to the story and the
characters and the idea that's what it
comes down to
um that makes that makes movies Stand
Out unique movies stand out to me
personally right so
it's the same with five second with a
five second render
exactly the same thing we're just on a
five second 120 frames
I don't know Edge did that answer your
question
um I think character design too is
another thing like come on
I think you get a little bit more points
if like you designed your own unique
character and it looks freaking awesome
and is designed really well
um than if you had pulled a Ronald
McDonald or something
um not to say that you can't win with
Ronald McDonald I'm just saying like the
more love and handcrafted
you know uniqueness you put into it uh
the further You're Gonna Go
um
and it's going to stand out you're gonna
have fun while you're doing it and
that's that's again the whole point of
all this yes there are winners like we
talked about yes there are prizes yes
there's top 100 and all this and that
yes there are montages top 100 that you
may or may not get into there's also the
all renders Montage too some people
don't make that because they submit and
their files are all janky I have a video
on that we'll get to that later okay
when the submission link is announced on
the 11th
um two weeks basically two weeks from
now
um
just FY I am I am streaming on Fridays
for this working month of August Fridays
all right I need my weekends y'all I
gotta stay sane I gotta be a person in
order to you know be a person I gotta be
a person
I felt like I was going somewhere with
some thought and I like
Sidetrack myself
like I was saying yes this is a
competition but at the same time it is
just for fun we're here to learn and
we're here to grow so have fun with it
you know if you can take the stakes off
of it for yourself
um you're really gonna flourish in that
setting if the if you're like put the
pressure on and it's just heated you
know you might freeze up in that
situation not worth it just take a step
back take a breath
have fun
um I would love to we're about an hour
in right now we're about 15 minutes in
I can answer more questions but I would
also like to start sketching out my idea
I have an idea that I want to do and I
want to sketch it out and you know start
building the elements of it for me
I think uh I got so used to doing the
same style I'm always going for photo
real dark and dramatic
um all the time all the time and
I kinda
got to the point where I'm like I'm not
having fun with this anymore it's not
fulfilling me anymore
um and that's that's a scary thought you
know then we get into burnout and and
like the thing I love isn't
what I love anymore oh no that's that's
scary and I think um
I've been I've been talking a lot about
this Rick Rubin book the creative act
and I've mentioned it a few times on the
stream I've talked about my burnout
before I've burnt out twice uh end of
last year end of the year before that
and I've been trying to work at it and
trying to figure out like what's the how
do I solve this how do I solve this the
Rick Rubin create the creative act book
that book
wow that really helped out a lot
um
let me get some water man I've been
talking straight for like 55 minutes
[Music]
it's good to be here with you guys
I wish we were all in chat together
speaking of that we can be because every
Monday this feels so staged
every Monday I'm hopping into the
Discord server
you know there's a link below and um
we're doing these virtual meetups every
single Monday throughout this challenge
um it's a chance for you guys to show
off your Works in progress this upcoming
one 31st
um this Monday the 31st
uh at noon Pacific Standard Time right
it's gonna we're gonna talk ideas we'll
be a little bit of back and forth right
now you guys can't chat with me I can
see you in the chat of course but we're
gonna get you know voice to voice here
um every Monday in the Discord server
um so please join the Discord
um go to the boss fight category and
you're gonna see get started and in
order to participate in order to uh to
in integrate yourself into the challenge
you're going to want to read all that
get started scroll to the bottom hit the
check mark icon the little check mark
Emoji at the bottom and that will give
you the boss fight role and it'll open
up all the channels for you guys so that
you can see
um any announcements that we make like
if there's an update
my goodness if there's an update to the
project files perhaps we'll let you know
if there's a submission link boom we're
gonna tag you boss fight bam so um and
then of course there is like a working
chat where you guys can all be in there
together and share there's people in
there right now
um there's voice channels too
and that's where we're gonna do these uh
stage chats every Monday
so please join us guys we're here to
support
throughout the whole challenge I'm here
every Friday streaming with you me
myself and the mods are here every
Monday
um doing a little voice chat with you
guys so it's gonna be fun I want it to
be as a uh interactive hangout kind of
experience as possible right because yes
you know we got a lot of Gamers here the
Lan parties are the best and I want to
try and get that as close as possible
with you guys
um
back to the idea I was talking about
like uh
he's talking about
style okay so I did the same style all
the time and I wasn't feeling too hot on
it and in this Rick Rubin book is why I
brought it up
he talks about is there a is there a a
different way you can go about doing
your
um your craft so for musicians
um you know he he is the producer not
producer he's like is it I don't know is
it the producer I don't know music terms
too much but he basically comes in and
he um
he gets the band to record their best
he's like the director I don't know he
gets the best out of the band so he went
in for the Red Hot Chili Peppers and
they were like man we've always done I
think it was like we've always done
Studio recordings for our last four
albums and we're kind of burnt out on
the studio recording thing and he was
like well let's do a house one let's do
like let's do the Lan parties situation
of an album let's get a nice house
um recording studio inside and let's
just hang out together for the weeks it
takes to put an album out and let's Jam
every day let's record all the stuff
we're doing and let's have fun with it
and they're like yeah that sounds great
they did that they put out their fifth
album right so
that's that was like his different spin
on the same process and that's kind of
what I'm trying to do in this challenge
with my art this time is I want to
tackle a different style I really want
to do something cartoony and fun and
colorful and animated and like I want to
bridge 2D and 3D with with my idea this
time around I have another idea that's
like dark and 3D and crazy right and
maybe we'll get around to doing too if
I'm lucky but for now I want to start
with this with this wild different crazy
style idea
um I want to
physically have my hand touching a pen
or a pencil onto some paper that is fun
to me I want to be coloring in with
crayons and markers and colored pencils
and outline and then cutting out with
scissors like I want to do that that's
fun to me
so I wanna
take those elements bring that into 3D
and do my final composition my final
animation
in 3D but build all my assets with like
hand cut out everything right so that to
me is fun
um
so
let's see here
how's the chat doing what's up guys
Dusty pixels you bet new challenge baby
we're doing it
foreign
good question will the prizes be for us
only or for all countries all countries
guys all countries we're not joking
around we're doing this all countries
International prizes getting shipped out
to Zimbabwe guys we're doing it
seriously
um Rococo they ship freaking worldwide
caft ships just about worldwide yes
there are countries for political
reasons that may be impossible to ship
to
we got we gotta address that all right
but that is outside of all of our
control
um for the majority though yes it is it
is international okay
thank you Dylan for for the for the kind
words
um
can you scale the boss to Hero size
oh so now this is getting you're getting
tricky tricky with it
technically
all right on the grand scheme of things
can you scale them down to Hero size uh
only if they are still in some way
taking up the area of Interest it has to
be big versus small that's like that's
rule number one replace the big boss and
the small hero with your own
if you can find out a way to scale the
boss down
but still have them appear large
there are ways I'm not going to say I'm
not going to say because we're gonna
have
80 people doing this thing
that's that's some like that's something
like thinking outside the box stretching
it far if you can pull it off
hats off to you you'd be bending them
rules oh God I died there I got like 90
for a second you would be bending those
rules for sure but like I said
you can bend the rules we have the rules
in place
to keep everyone fitting into the
Montage but if you are going to bend
them it takes them you're going to be
taking a creative risk that's on you
if you can if you can pull it off
hats off to you though
ah
can the animation take place in a
vehicle I don't know if you can make it
work if you can make it work
um speaking of animations guys I
recorded a bunch of motion captured
animations with the Rococo suit
um there's like a handful of them in the
starter files for you guys
um we got some fun ones they're just
idea starters for you they're not
mandatory it literally says optional
motion capture files so you guys can use
those in your renders if you want
um that's totally cool figure out fun
ways to use it I had fun recording them
um or you know if you just want to use
them as idea starters and kind of come
up with something on top of that or
completely different that's totally fine
but they're just there to help some
people who are maybe just beginning and
they need a little help like I don't
know how to do my own animation well
that's why they're there for you guys
can the can the boss be an environmental
hazard
um
how you interpret boss fight is up to
you I will leave it at that
deep note of that area of Interest all
right
um
can the boss okay so now we're getting
questions that we've hit before most of
these questions you guys are asking are
in the FAQs so do yourself a favor go to
the Discord pull up the get started
scroll down I have the FAQ thread down
there open that up read those FAQs they
will help you out I promise a lot of
these questions here most of these
questions here are in the FAQs all right
so go check it out please read that
first then come back and ask me
questions that are not in the FAQs we're
at that point now because I've answered
pretty much everyone
um
okay
how am I gonna build out my uh oh
hopefully there was a limiter on the mic
there
so does I think there was
ah
[Music]
Saul you're headed off to school for 3D
animation this fall you've been a huge
inspiration and I want to thank you for
all you've done that's what's up man
congratulations on 3D animation school
um I know it's a good time so to Monte
you're crushing that 3D animation school
right now
um you're like halfway through or
something I think right do you can you
chat in the chat Soto
no he's scrambling he's getting his
things together
[Music]
can you can you talk on the stream like
don't you do okay it's not set up right
now yeah he's um he's loving that that
uh
that that animation school good times
you got a heart attack
all right guys
um last thing before we move on we got
boss fight stickers all right there's a
link down below
um it's actually a sticker sheet this
time let me show you I'm gonna show you
what this thicker sheet looks like
let me go over to the old website
you guys here in just a second
boom
boss fight stickers look at this look at
this look at this
right here there's a sticker sheet we
got one two three four five six seven
eight stickers on this thing for you
guys uh ship worldwide try to keep it as
cheap as I can I know 17 plus tax is a
little pricey for a sticker sheet I get
it I get it
um but the the chunk that the company is
taking to print the stickers and build
all the things you know I gotta account
for that all this and that right but
these things are pretty sweet
look at this nice little close-up view
nice little close-up view I love it I
have um
endless engine stickers let me show you
the endless engines stickers
but just to give you an idea of scale
right of sizing
this one is seen
it's fair share of handling but
boom little sticker sheet right gives
you an idea
kind of what what the sticker sheet is
going to be looking like
um but yeah it's like a fun way to
collect some some challenge swag for you
guys and I'm going to be giving some out
here on the stream I'm giving some out
on the stream
um I'd like to give out
I don't know like five or so
um
I think the first my first thought would
be to do like a random drawing and then
if I have some trivia questions maybe we
can have some masks some trivia
questions here
um but we'll get there we'll get there
let's uh let's hop over let's get
creating some art
all right
so I want to open up Photoshop
actually let's go
30 40 by
1620 I think is what we're doing
proceed
yes this is our format nice widescreen
format
um let's see let's see let's see
[Music]
let's get set up here
and get a little brush go in
[Music]
let's see if we can set up a nice little
brush here
um something with like pen pressure
[Music]
charcoal
racer okay
um
God it's so rare I rarely drawn
Photoshop here guys
brushes is that like brush settings
yeah
there we go
[Music]
Photoshop come on
good oh goodness
um let's see how do we do it ship ship
shape
Dynamics size angle
[Music]
battery
eyes around us
I know one of these is uh
I don't know
uh
maybe we'll just take the flow down
the opacity down a little bit we'll go
with that
[Music]
was this it
foreign
here we go pen pressure opacity
why does it not
I don't know why
it won't work
it should work the pen pressure
anyway
so what I'm thinking for my idea here
oh
all right
foreign
so let's see
right we have our our hero
and we have our our boss essentially
kind of chilling up here
so I want to do like a
little Sumo scene
and he's like up in the air right he
like jumps up in the air
[Music]
um
foreign
can we do
something like this
the ring
this would probably be the close project
file there's close medium and far and
this one would probably be the close one
and he's got like the
little ceremonial
Garb going
and then be like
so when we saw a Sumo match in uh in
Japan they had all these guys like walk
around the ring with um
with like advertise they were like
banners
but I think they were ads
so it'd be cool to have these guys like
walking around
with their like Banner ad things
and the ads are just like flying up
[Music]
from this dude's like wind
whoa
it'd be like Rippling in the wind you
know
and the plan is to actually draw all
this out for real on paper and cut them
out and like use them as like little 2D
planes and just have all these 2D planes
and have different like animated
versions of each one
to give you that nice like Ripple in the
wind kind of thing
oh man yeah throwing salt in slow-mo
definitely
um but this guy's up in the air he's
like
right he was leaping up into the air
this guy
so maybe what we do is like I could grab
his lair
get up in here
foreign
[Music]
and our guy here is like just down here
trembling
hero not much of a hero
so he's like
down here
oh boy
like no chance right and I'm gonna
figure out the story on it like maybe
he Dodges at the last minute and the
dude like bounces out of the stage or
something but yeah this guy being up in
the air in slow-mo would be pretty sweet
and in the background so we're gonna be
pretty low the camera angle's gonna be
pretty low so
I'll probably cut it off here
but the background is like this cool
like um
I don't know what it would be an octagon
I think it is an octagon yeah
so the bleachers kind of go up here
and then there's this like top row
[Music]
and there's just all these people like
sitting around the ring
[Music]
so we got like all these people just
chilling here
foreign
go down people in the front so it's
gonna be a lot I'm gonna have to figure
out how to do like the crowd but I think
I'm just gonna draw them in they're
gonna be like animated little guys just
drawn in bobbing up and down like their
hands up in the air very reminiscent of
like uh old fighting games or boxing
games maybe where this crowd is just
like the two frames like this you know
um
and I can get us
as detail as I want with it but I think
just selling the abstract nature of like
a crowd here would be the goal
right just a bunch of heads in the crowd
[Music]
all through all back here up in the
stands
[Music]
and it'll be sweet so like the dude is
in the air right the Sumo guys up in the
air jumping in the air so that's the
slo-mo part
and I want to have like an elemental
effect to it all too
um
so having all these like add bearers
these guys with all these ad
um
Banner things it would be like
swooping up into the air
and do
one
but white or something
there we go
[Music]
so like dust would be kicked up
and maybe that's where like some
emerging can come in
[Music]
when he leaps it's like a big Elemental
thing
and the flags are whipping in the wind
too
right so there's like a lot of wind
going on
his little tassels I think could be
Rippling
hair could be moving a little bit you
know
these little tassel guys are probably
moving in the wind as well
so if you guys hadn't uh
Realize by now
this is me just brainstorming I'm just
coming up with stuff seeing what works
um I can walk you guys through my other
idea too in a minute
but
right now
I'm gonna finish up this one
all this crowd back here
I think they'll kind of be going off
into the Shadows a little bit
however so let me ask you guys how are
you guys doing how many of you guys feel
like you definitely have an idea and how
many of you guys feel like
um you're gonna take the next few days
to come up with the best idea from maybe
a pot of a few ideas that you're kind of
gonna
gonna think about over the next couple
days let me know what you guys think
I'll take a look at the chat here
foreign
that's good
no ideas okay no 10 ideas no ideas you
have an idea okay got an idea
um so it looks like people have an idea
of what's going on
five ideas but trying to pick one cool
yeah I'm kind of in the same boat
two ideas that you want to flesh out yes
yes that's where I'm at I have two ideas
that I that I want to flush out and I'm
excited for both which is good
[Music]
yeah
sweet you got tall Mac you think of a
good one you're gonna refine it
yeah you have to manage this in a trip
okay so here's the thing yes guys we
also have life too and we have to we
have to balance this project and life
can't just be the project we got a lot
of things going on
um so that's another thing we have to
figure out the best way to make a little
bit of progress on this every day or
most days
um
foreign
keep the ball moving forward
because you don't know what's going to
happen you know you might have something
come up with work you might have someone
come up with school
Etc
um you know you might have an
opportunity to go do something with a
friend that you really want to do that
you should do so I think it's all about
balancing work and life here guys and
making sure that
um
you know you stay healthy throughout the
process
definitely want to keep it healthy
can you change the depth of field yeah
100 you can definitely change the depth
of field so camera you know one of the
FAQs is can I touch the camera we say no
um use one of the three starter files
that we that we offer
um
but when it comes to like depth of field
yeah you can touch the camera that with
that um depth of field is fine camera
Shake also fine
um
the shutter speed all that stuff motion
blur of course of course of course
yeah I can't wait to like
actually start drawing this out I'm very
excited for it
can we do drawings on uh on a live chat
let's do a drawing for some stickers
let's get you guys some stickers
let's see
engage with your audience let's see uh
start a poll answer start a q a
okay now
you guys know a good website for like
random drawings
let's see
random drawing website
random picker raffle drawing get started
interest sign in what's the quickest way
to do this
I just want to send you guys a link
and try to sign up
Alterna what's up thanks for joining
thanks for joining
oh okay blender man what's the one guy
Collins had up earlier
[Music]
see sotomontay
random idea generator
[Music]
magma Studio let me check that out
draw no not like ah
not like a random no a random drawing
like uh like a sweepstakes drawing
do it through Discord or something like
I feel like I'm just gonna have to
scroll here I think I think we could do
it like this like this is janky
but I'm just gonna scroll
and like put my mouse down or something
and then whichever one it lands on
yeah Lottery
all right we ain't doing the scrolling
thing right now
I don't know Soda Montague do you think
you could help me out do you think you
could figure out a way to uh
okay so so does on the case I'm gonna
keep working on my art and we're gonna
see if we can't do a little drawing for
you guys and get you some uh some free
stickers
so I think we'll do it with like a
little Spotlight thing here right so
the crowd would kind of be out of focus
um
dimly lit and the way that the actual
like
ring is lit there's a big old spotlight
just above right so
um let's try
bring these guys out just a little bit
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sweet okay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I'm feeling good with this something
like this
um
hey I like that a lot
so this idea one I'll sketch out idea
two as well
foreign
[Music]
okay
all right so that's one I think this
would be yeah like I said the close
project file
um
see
right I think that's that's probably
they can we can fit these guys in a ring
right
here one so the other idea I have is
actually
um more of a
probably making use of the medium
project file so I'll show you the medium
one
it's more in the background
right
something like that
but basically my idea is to have like uh
I want to do a scene where a guy like
pulls a road flare in a cave and lights
up this underground like layer area
with this giant rock wall that's like
the monster a rock monster and there's a
lake
in between the hero like the heroes on
an island or in a boat or something and
he pulls
pulls a flare and it illuminates this
giant like
this giant boss in front of him or
something I think that could be sweet
oh friends you uploaded your submission
already dude nice
should be actually impossible because
there's no submission like yet it comes
out on the 11th for you guys
um there's no rush on this definitely no
rush
does it have to be 1v1
um not necessarily you can add more
characters uh More Heroes per se to the
scene but your main Hero has to stand
out from the others there has to be one
clearly defined like main hero
so if you want to do Power Rangers say
for instance like
there'd be like the one Power Ranger in
the middle and then a couple off to the
side or something you know the rest off
to the side
like how would you do that let's see
[Music]
foreign
maybe something like this and then like
making this one like
brighter or something or Spotlight on
this one or you know something to to
make clear that this is the main one
depending on like the animation as well
could could help you with that
could be fun
thank you
[Music]
all right looks like we got the raffle
up in the Discord under announcements
boss fight announcements
all right Soto says we are giving away
five boss fight sticker sheets join the
raffle in the next 30 minutes
um so you would just hit enter
and then I guess I'm gonna click view
giveaway that is that
see
if I click it now does that like end it
got it okay
yeah all right guys so
um
head over to the Discord
in the boss fight
challenge uh category under
announcements
the BF announcement
Channel
just go there and hit hit that little
enter boom then I'll give away five five
stickers so don't say thank you
for setting that up that was nice very
nice
[Music]
all right let's um let's draw out the
next idea
all right so for this one I want to do
a hero
like maybe they're in like a cape or
something I don't know
and they have a
they're holding like a road flare
right and then
maybe they're standing on like a little
uh
a little island or something
I've been playing a lot of Zelda
recently so maybe there's a treasure
chest right here chilling
maybe some coins who knows you know
there's some stuff
on the ground
maybe he's got a little bud with him
[Music]
who knows
right and
he's gonna pull that flare and in the
background let's say there's gonna be
[Music]
like a lake I'm imagining this just
being like a a bunch of water here
[Music]
I read this book recently called the
hike
and it's like it's insane it's about
this dude who just goes on this
ridiculous adventure and there's a
moment in the middle of the book where
he comes across this like Giant
and it's totally reminding me of this
right now
um
and then up here I don't know how like
what I'm gonna do for their face here
but it's gonna be some sort of giant
like
thing uh let's try like
maybe it's like has a big old rock hand
right here just a bunch of rocks
rock pile
and like its face would be I don't know
maybe it's faces uh
cave so like the water
kind of flows into this cave
but it's its mouth or something
it's like kind of like The Goonies you
know like when they go
and you realize that they were in this
giant skeleton
mouth they were hanging out in a
skeleton kind of like that like if this
was like the big old
Skeleton thing
and man I'm pretty bad at drawing but
rocks you know rocks a bunch of rocks
chilling out here
maybe has like
another hand
right it's just this creature ingrained
into the stone
and up here would be like
eventually it would connect with the
ceiling
and there'd be like a lot of these
little guys chilling
maybe there's a side path back there I
don't know
foreign
test up here who knows another one
its mouth is just like Darkness it's all
about the lighting here so he pulls the
pulls the flare
and it and it lights this whole thing up
in red
and reveals this this creature
who's maybe like mid standing up or
something I don't know
yeah
so
um Claymore kex
um you said every time you see an idea
it's like you have the ideas and the
knowledge but not enough to actually
make it look great
um same for me same for me same for me
I am not the best at a lot of things
when it comes to 3D but I know that I do
enjoy making environments right so
I'm literally doing that now I'm kind of
making an environmental boss where he's
a little bit more static I would have to
figure out my the slo-mo element I don't
quite know what the slo-mo element would
be on this one but maybe the rocks are
falling down like maybe it's like a
um
you know we have like different pieces
falling
place is coming apart and it could be
like could be like that or something
um it could have like certain elements
of this thing where like
maybe when he pulls the flare it like
disperses some of the rocks and the
rocks will like
kind of come out and then come back
together in a certain way or something
I'm not sure
this one's all about the lighting
for sure
[Music]
so let's see if we can't start adding
some
Shadow to this thing
[Music]
so he's gonna hit with the flare and
like this stuff will pretty much be in
Shadow
all this stuff will probably be in
Shadow but it's going to be catching
like little bits of the
flare
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
out
from the flare
probably have his own shadow
foreign
[Music]
make the soft glow across
all this
to fade out as we get
more to the outside
top
[Music]
definition on these guys
and this looks kind of janky
um it's hard to Define like
the shape of this thing I'm wondering
maybe instead of lighting up the eyes we
just darken them really intensely
foreign
[Music]
part of the whole thing because
it's the source of the flare right
something like that you know
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
back some of that detail
highlight detail
it's definitely would have been smart to
do this in like another layer
but you know
[Music]
I don't know something like that
thank you
[Music]
foreign
yeah
that's cool I'm down for that
I think that's a fun one
save that as my idea too
[Music]
sweet all right
yeah so
my goal at least with this
um and my advice to you guys would be to
think about the prompt for a little bit
um
really dwell on it for for a couple days
these ideas didn't come to me
immediately they came from of course
like you know we were building the
project file for a month
um but I didn't know what I wanted to
really do until maybe like a week ago
um and the idea just kind of hit me so I
would suggest take the weekend to really
think about it to kind of uh you know
ingrain yourself in in this
thinking about it really at the end of
the day keep thinking about it pull
references
um look at different examples different
ideas and come up with a handful of them
come up with a handful of ideas that you
think could be cool
um once you have a handful of ideas that
you think would all be pretty sweet
comes down to like which idea gets you
the most exciting
so because you're going to be working on
this for you know four weeks essentially
right the deadline is uh August
27th that's a Sunday night at 11 59 PM
Pacific Standard time so when I wake up
Monday morning all the submissions are
there and that gives me uh just a little
under a week to pull the top 100 and the
winners with RAF grassetti's help for
the live stream the judging stream the
next the next week right so
um it's going to be a very short
turnaround
so basically once you guys deliver your
art a week later we'll have the results
um
but yeah what you want to do take the
weekend come up with a number of ideas
and pick the one that you really want to
do that you think will be fun that you
think will be doable but also at the
same time push you a little further
because we want to all you know grow
during this as well right so that's a
that's the idea with this whole thing
and um
yeah I wouldn't just go with your first
idea even if it is a good idea give
yourself just a little bit of time to uh
to sit with it and to see see what comes
up
on the on Monday the 31st July 31st
um I'm going to be doing like a little
virtual Meetup with you guys on the
Discord server so you guys will be able
to uh to hop in ask questions talk about
your idea if you want
um
you know maybe if you ask this is valid
or not
that that's that's fine at the end of
the day it's up to you it's and it's
kind of a thing here
let me actually address that really
quick
a lot of people ask myself in the
moderators is this idea okay is this
idea okay like we can't really give you
we can't say yes or no
um
because we we can't there's too many
people and it's not everyone it's not
the moderator's jobs to say yes your
idea is fine no it's not and then if
they win or lose they're like oh the
modern assault no
we're not doing that
um but on Mondays on like the the little
virtual meetups that we have on Discord
we do talk about your idea you know so
you'll come up you'll be like hey this
is what I'm feeling and it's our time
that's the window to give like a little
advice like hey you know this is a cool
idea and we'll keep it all positive
we're not going to be like saying ah
this is gonna suck you know blah blah
um unless it's like clearly something is
like standing out here and like a rule
might be broken that could be our time
to publicly say like hey guys notice
this is a good example of a rule that
might need a little tweaking let's go
ahead and you know point the artist in
the right direction that's the time for
that so
um just as a way to help you guys out
and throw away to it be a little bit
more personal uh personal experience
because even though we're live streaming
right and I see you guys in the chat
it's still nice to be talking back and
forth
we're coming up on on noon and I think
um what we're gonna do here is Judge the
weekly challenge there's one more weekly
challenge
um because when we're not doing these
full 3d Community challenges the
month-long was we're doing weekly
challenges every week on my Discord
server it's like inktober think of it
like inktober if you're into drawing
um where you get a prompt every day this
is a prompt every week so
um we're gonna go ahead and judge that
um do you guys have any questions for me
before we do that
um
you know what I'm gonna answer questions
afterwards I'm gonna answer questions
afterwards this you know
join me for this it'll be really cool
we're gonna see some cool art I promise
um and then uh I'll hang out with you
guys for just a little bit longer and
then I gotta get some food at a certain
point so
um you know hold your questions
oh of course yes and we will see who won
the giveaway for the stickers right
after we do the uh the weekly challenge
review so I think it's time to hop in uh
shall we Soto
let's do it
all right guys
so
bam
we're doing it the weekly challenge
winner set up let me get this full
screen here let me bring this over to
the other monitor so I'm looking at the
art
all right
so
the The Prompt was
um
what's the problem it's like hidden
passage or something let me let me
double check that for you guys
all right
secret passions seek secret passage was
the prompt
um it's a busy week y'all busy week so
let's see what secret passages you guys
have rendered out this week
starting with
wondrous congratulations for winning
this thing man super awesome
um beautiful beautiful piece of art you
put together
man
um
your color and your lighting and your
composition and your idea
is just great dude say no more
um I love the like what is it called uh
ah there's a place in Ireland
oh shoot I brought it up on stream
before and forgot what it was and
someone told me a Giant's Causeway is
what it was called it has all of these
like rocks shaped like this
um because they believed that a giant
came by and did some stuff to the to the
landscape and made the Rocks like look
like this
um and I think there's a couple spots
around the world but anyway
this is freaking awesome man you should
be very proud of this congratulations on
the win you got you get 15 points
towards your role on the server
um
towards your rank we do art ranks it's
kind of like Pokemon badges but with art
it's pretty sweet so congratulations
wondrous
for this dude the camera Shake is
perfect
dang
oh
so good uh who's next who's next
we got Jack to hack Jack the hack put
together a short film
and it's actually halfway through the
short film can you can you start it over
real quick
here we go here we go this is it this is
it
putting together a whole short film man
in a week I love it
it's well lit too good camera movement
great composition good color
really nice cinematic shots
beautiful lighting coming into the
window there oh snap what's that
I don't I don't like that
[Music]
uh
oh my God
it's loose
it's loose congratulations Jack the hack
for when it is like a Hershey's bar at
the end there Hershey's bar door that's
good really good stuff congratulations
man you killed it I love it your shots
were very cinematic
um very thought out the lighting is
perfect your animation was good like
really great job knocked it out in a
week man congratulations who's next
sonamonte who's next
this one's so good dude look at this
look at this secret passage in the
forest
and it just leads you back to the same
spot
oh
incredible
dude your animation your lighting the
idea
everything's coming together here could
have used a little bit more uh samples a
little bit more render time looks a
little like swimmy a little like blotchy
looking but hey that's all right
you did a great job
oh man some like loose pine straw
on the trap door some leaves that just
drops down into the darkness would be
pretty sweet
not gonna lie but hey dude
congratulations it's beautiful the
concept the execution the lighting the
color the camera work everything you're
knocking out what's the word you're God
this is what happens guys you get to the
end of a stream you talk straight for
two hours and you know what you're
saying anymore
you're firing on all cylinders you're
knocking it out the park that's what I'm
trying to say who's next
we got two more winners oh
oh
Naz
Naz Nas this is incredible
beautiful the lighting here the detail
the camera like angle the freaking the
color
the render quality just looks photo real
this is insane
um I would want to discover this
be the best um I think I was talking
about this like last stream I was
talking about
a cave system in Vietnam I think that
has its own ecosystem it rains in the
cave and like uh
there's like all these trees growing in
the cave and it looks like this and I'm
all about this this is amazing
congratulations Naz for the win and who
who's who's the last one sodomontay
scouty dude
beautiful the lighting on that super
nice
I love the concept I'd be up in there
for sure easily I'd be up in there
uh with a camera a little light you know
it'd be a good old time
but uh man your render quality your
lighting the idea the color on it
everything is super solid super super
solid
Jan I don't know what's wrong with my
camera
I'm gonna try turning it off and turning
it back on let's see
all right
all right are we back
are we back
maybe maybe not I don't know
Dark Times
just
oh something's happening
[Music]
all right guys moving on
moving on we'll see we'll see
uh we got honorable mentions because
that wasn't it
um
oh man what have we done what have we
done to ourselves
um let's get some honorable mentions in
because uh these aren't the only awesome
pieces of art that come in for the
weekly challenge who's up first
Eloy
really nice
beautiful piece to get me put together
here uh beautiful lighting beautiful
render quality camera angle the color
that you're using of course secret
passage being the the actual prompt for
this week really nice use of that
um super solid man yeah I'd be up in
there in two seconds
I don't know it's just me but I'd be up
in there for sure
um each one of you guys get fives uh
gets Five Points to your to your rank
here on the server for honorables and
the if you participate you get one point
who's next
Target rat
something yes
um dude love it love it what's that game
where like you have you're a little kid
it's by the people who Mitch out of the
Colossus and uh
you have like this giant like mouse rat
thing that flies around
it reminds me of that right that game it
reminds me of that game
it's beautiful man I love the lighting
your design here is is really nice
and the design language is actually
consistent throughout the entire piece
perfect knocking it out
what's next
subdivided my face what a name what a
render the render quality and the
lighting off the charts this um this is
great actually because I have a book
called the giant I think it's called the
giant stepwells of India or the
stepwells of India
and um it's just a photo book of all
these incredible places like this like
we're seeing and man
uh there are some cool places on this
planet let me tell you this is a great
interpretation of that you're dude the
photorealism on this is ridiculous I'd
love to see a short film take place here
that would be sweet
congratulations on the honorable mention
crazy is that who's next
crazy all right
um I like it you like your secret
passage is more like a secret bus ride
and I thought that was cool I love the
lighting I love your composition I
thought it looked very cinematic
um that's like I love that kind of stuff
man uh you did a great great job with
this one
yeah all of these could easily be
winners man like they're so good who's
next
loan who
Lonesome lonesome
um
yeah this is another good one look the
render quality the lighting super
dramatic super dark
really good stuff man subtle blue in the
sky and then like something some that
that blue reflected off the door I don't
know exactly what that is but
looks cool to me man I dig it congrats
Lonesome who's next Soto
oh Paul we know our boy Paul shout outs
Paul this is a this is some good stuff
man this is one of my favorite pieces
that you've put together to be honest
I'm a huge fan of Half-Life not that
this has anything to do with that but it
kind of reminds me of it
um yeah this is this is freaking
wonderful your colors are nice the
orange red from the suit with the blue
in the background
um I love that concrete man that looks
so nice the graffiti is really well done
too
my only note would be to wing wing out
the uh the character and the lamp
so your character is just a little bit
more in between that like barricade
so that their hand isn't touching the
light pole it'll just make their
silhouette a little bit more read clear
I feel like they're a little crunched up
against the the wall there
um but man you're knocking it out look
you even got the fireflies up in the
light too
really good stuff man
congrats Paul who's next
Pinnacle dude this
this is so good
this is so good so good um I wanted this
to win
I really wanted this to win it was a it
was a little bit more of a block out
though
um to win I think you needed a little
bit more detail in the water a little
bit more detail on the Rocks these guys
are standing next to maybe a touch more
detail in the castle but your shapes are
perfect do nothing else like your shapes
are killing it
um I love that it's just
the top of an image a dark middle and
the bright like bottom part of the
bottom third it's everything we need to
know the locations are connected because
of the colors
um and like you're doing so much with so
little this is really good
seriously
um if you brought this out to like a Max
Max mode you finish the water a little
bit you put a little bit more time into
those rocks holy crap man
um yeah that's cool
uh who's next solomontay
scratch
yeah this one's super cool combining two
mediums you got the photorealism with
like
um the more traditional 2D animation
I love it I think it's a super cool
style
um and the 2D animation the character of
course is like blended into the footage
they're composited in lit like you would
actually be if they were there in 3D
um I'm curious to see what your workflow
is like maybe you had a 3D character and
then you painted painted in the 2D
character to actually match the lighting
I think it's really really cool I love
it
who's next Soto
oh this one's got no name snap
you know that's why it's important to
name your art
like your Discord name
all right so this one is cool I really
like it because uh lighting composition
big fan big fan
um the the hero of the character is very
very uh
visible because of the silhouette the
lighting that you chose says good use of
lighting here your render quality is
really nice photorealistic scene really
nice blocking I just I thought it was
really Pleasant to look at so I wanted
to shout you out
who's next Soto
why readle yes
so this one's cool man I I love it
because of uh photorealism your steps
are beautiful the work you put in there
on the steps lighting super solid
um I just wanted to shout you out for
that and then you got the little story
on the bottom left here
it would have been cool to have that a
little closer a little higher up um I
think it could be a little bit more in
it's just a little touch out
um a frame I think seeing a little bit
more of that would be nice
um but I love it you got that little
secret Adventure you got going and it
actually
goes down the steps too like if you look
at the map you can see that there's like
little there's a secret passage this is
great use of the prompt
and I think that's it guys I think
that's it
oh we got one more we got one more all
right so the monkey throw it at me
this one this is by mule
we almost missed him you know
this one's so good yeah this one easily
could have won too it's ah it loops
there's a story here
there's like
really nice character to the character I
guess for lack of a better word they're
walking in a very specific way that's
unique to them
a lot of character going on in this one
and I love that tile the blue tile super
cool
stealing that cherry tomato you gotta
you gotta do what you got to do
to get that food
yes
good stuff good stuff congratulations
guys to the honorable mentions to the
winners and for everyone participating
in these weekly challenges I really do
appreciate it it's so clear it's so
obvious and I hope it's obvious and
clear to you guys
that you all are leveling up
and you're getting really good
um it'd be cool to do a comparison to
like people's
first weekly challenges to to where
they're at now some of you guys have
been doing these for an insane amount of
time like wondrous I think you might be
on a 40 50 I don't know you're on some
crazy streak
Paul you've been doing it for a long
time
um Naz you've been up
you've been up at it for a while
objective as well
um
uh who else uh metatrox I know you've
been up and at it like crazy you guys
have really been doing a great job and
staying consistent with it and growing
and it's really showing it is so let's
see if I can get this camera back up I'm
gonna restart my camera again son of
Monte
and uh
yeah I'll see you guys in a minute
um give me a second and we're gonna get
this camera back up and then I'll answer
any more questions you have in the next
like five or ten and we're gonna give
away those stickers don't don't move
your butts we're giving away the
stickers be back in two seconds get this
camera back up and running
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
guys we're doing it we're giving away
five boss fight sticker sheets uh we did
a random drawing on Discord
and now is the time to reveal who do we
got settlement who won the thing
yes all right so if you have your name
here on screen hit me up on Discord
um I'm gonna be looking for your message
okay and you're gonna get your email
address
um I'm not gonna get your email address
I'm gonna get your address all right and
I'm gonna send you a boss fight sticker
sheet on me
um they're super cool it's a full-on
sticker sheet bunch of sweet a bunch of
sweet boss fight stickers that my buddy
gave peregrino designed so
yeah heck yeah if you guys want to go
pick up one for yourself please
um uh there's a link down below check it
out it goes to my noisegreen and
light.com website where I got all my art
prints and everything I got some
stickers up there too
um pick one up I'll probably be doing a
little bit more giveaways on the coming
streams I'm doing it every Friday okay
so every Friday I'll be joining you guys
on stream and I hope to see you
this upcoming Friday I hope to have
um kind of like a a version of my art a
version of My Scene ready for you guys
um but before then
I'll see you on Monday July 31st on the
Discord server we're going to be doing a
little face to face we're gonna be
bringing you guys up to chat with us
about your ideas about where you're at
so far and helping you out along the way
we're doing that every Monday okay
um so have have fun with this my
goodness guys this is gonna be awesome I
cannot wait to see all of your renders
together in one long stream of awesome
talent and art you guys really crush it
every time we do these have fun with it
please guys have fun that's number one
all right if you have any questions I'll
see on Discord until next time peace out
guys see you Monday on Discord and then
Friday for another live stream peace out
y'all
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]